l'enseigne Virgine dépose le bilan les
syndicats ont rencontré le principal
actionnaire Butler Capital Partners hier
mais la situation n'a connu aucune
avancée 1000 à 1200 emplois sont menacés
dans les 26 magasins en France don ceux
de Montini le Bretonneux dans le centre
commercial Sky West bonsoir Sylvain
alias bonsoir vous êtes délégué syndical
Sud pour le Virgin vous êtes salarié du
magasin de Montini le Bretonneux vous
siégez aussi au comité d'entreprise
aujourd'hui que demandent les syndicats
avec ce dépôt de
bilan demande déjà à ce que
l'actionnaire d'Ur cap partnerire prenne
toute ses responsabilités dans cette
histoire parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que si Virgine aujourd'hui
dépose le bilan cert bon les comment
dire
euh les tout ce qui est Internet et
effectivement la la culture
dématérialisée en ligne est à prendre en
compte mais surtout à prend en compte
c'est la responsabilité de B Capital
Partners qui a mis tout simplement tout
droit à Virgine en situation de toute
façon de pant aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
est possible d'imaginer un repreneur de
relancer l'activité Virgin de développer
pourquoi pas aussi également l'activité
sur Internet et de rattraper le retard
pris ces dernières années alors à
l'heure actuelle un trouver un repreneur
malheureusement vu la situation qui
s'est fortement dégradé euh ça serait je
dirais presque un un miracle voilà
malheureusement donc pour vous
aujourd'hui la situation semble presque
impossible he pour l'avenir de de
Virgine c'est c'est pas véritablement
une surprise pour vous on a entendu les
les syndicats les salariés s'exprimer
ces derniers jours et au regard de ce
qui a été mené par la la l'entreprise
ces dernières années c'est une c'est un
dénouement malheureusement assez logique
euh oui c'est c'est pas une surprise
nous on voyait bien effectivement même
dans les magasins et autres les chiffres
se dégradé tu suis au comitaire
entreprise effectivement voilà on voyait
également voilà puisque donc le comité
entreprise est habé à intervenir quelque
peu dans l'entreprise sur les questions
économiques et autres on voyait
effectivement que même
Virgine Virgine stor avait de plus en
plus une
trésorerie de plus en plus dégradé voilà
et on voyait effectivement que même
voilà le le danger se rapprochait dans
tout ce qui est l'existance même de de
l'entreprise il y a eu des mobilisations
aujourd'hui un peu partout en France
principalement sur les champ lisé là où
se trouve le magasin emblématique un
petit peu de cette ancienne Vergine
est-ce que sur montinil bretonneuse
sa-quentin en Yveline des actions un
mouvement est prévu dans les prochains
jours à ma connaissance non il faut
savoir que bon historiquement dans les
magasins Virgin le magasin de Montin
bretonux est l'un des plus nouveaux
entre gu magasin de région parisienne et
il n'y a jamais eu vraiment de de
culture syndicale ou même de culture de
mobilisation parmi le personnel de du
magasin donc il avit peut-être euh
aujourd'hui sur leschangisé d'une
manière individuelle des collègues de ce
magasin mais sinon je n'ai pas été
sollicité par les collègues du magasin
sur on a une éventuelle mobilisation et
autr et au niveau national quelle sera
l'action des syndicats alors au niveau
national bon les syndicats effectivement
en train d'Er le personnel hein
là-dessus voilà je tout le monde pense
que c'est une des meilleures solutions
et également bon vu de toute façon il
faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui donc la
présence de Virgine stor a déposé donc
le dossier de dépôt de bilan auprès du
tribunal de commerce et on pense qu'il y
a quelque chose juridique à faire parce
qu'il faut savoir que le comité
entreprise d'hier n'avait donné n'ait
rendu aucun avis concernant ce dépôt de
bilan auprès du du tribunal de commerce
et donc que voilà il y a il y a des l
d'entrave de la part de la direction de
merci Sylvin alias pour ces précisions
je rappelle que vous êtes délégué
syndical sudvgine titulaire du comité
d'entreprise salarié du magasin du Sky
West du du Virgin Megastor à Montini le
Bretonneux et situation de cessation de
paiement pour Virgine situation qui
reste difficile bien sûr pour les
quelques 1000 salariés merci à vous à
suivre l'événement sport du weekend sans
transition laavenue d'xer à guillancour
pour une rencontre de la coupe
gambardela pour le moment nous allons
faire les soldes premers jours des
soldes d'hivers aujourd'hui dans un
contexte économique difficile qu'en
attendent les commerçant quelques
réponses avec Joanna souri et Guillaume
camps c'est parti pour les soldes
d'hiver du 9 janvier au 12 février le
centre commercial de Saint-Quentin en
Yvin met en place différentes opérations
de marketing ce matin ouverture des
magasins des 8h30 en plus pour les les
clients qui étaient dans le centre ils
avaient le droit à un petit déjeuner
offert par les commerçants c'est une
manière de de les accueillir leur dire
bon bienvenue pour les solldes et puis B
voilà de se faire plaisir quoi parmi les
clients déjà nombreux certains font
preuve d'organisation j'avais déjà fait
repérage la semaine dernière et et là
c'est bon je voilà j'achète ce que
j'avais prévu d'acheter il y a encore
les tailles donc profitons-eni je suis
chargé de faire les courses aussi pour
mon mari donc du coup du coup voilà
meuble à là en général on essaie de se
faire une petite cagnotte pour justement
pouvoir en profiter quand quand ce sont
les soldes on a à peu près 100 € pour
chacun vous avez un budget
oui il faut pas que ça dépasse allez les
200 € en même temps bah je regarde je
sais pas je regarde cherche des costards
éventuellement mais j'attends déjà que
ce soit moins cher et puis voilà essayer
de faire de bonnes
affaires on commence toujours par entre
20 et 30 % au début pour finir à la fin
vraiment fin des soldes à 50 % on
nattaque pas sur des prix à 70 % comme
pourrait le faire certains on préfère
avoir un prix qui soit tout en en
adéquation avec nos produits on
sélectionne pas on met réellement tout
le magasin toute la collection donc de
la saison en solde ça une grosse partie
du du du travail de l'année hein comme
en fait toutes les périodes de sold
c'est aussi bien celle d'été mais c'est
vrai que sold de divhers bah ça
représente oui beaucoup dans cette
boutique de prête apporté pour homme les
soldes de divhivers correspondent à 20 %
du chiffre d'affaires malgré la crise le
magasin espère dépasser ce pourcentage
pour faire mieux que dernier la période
des sols s'achèvera le 12 février avec
une ouverture spéciale dimanche 13
janvier dans plusieurs centres
commerciaux de la
région